from above it looks like a lake but in
fact it's a wetland system known as a
Cienega the landscape is actually hilly
but during the rainy season overflowing
rivers form freshwater meadows
transforming it into a swamp
it's a biotope that's home to an
extraordinary variety of plant life fish
and fauna the people who live here are
used to a landscape that changes with
the seasons there are some 1900 Cienega
in Columbia of varying sizes one of the
largest the Cienega disappered osa is
under threat oh myyy Duran hell is a
fisherwoman she and her seven children
live on the island of barranco Nez the
local fisher folk are well aware that
the Cienega is suffering there used to
be many many more fish huge fish in
general there was much more wildlife but
lots of species have died out they've
just disappeared there are species that
younger generations don't know because
they don't exist anymore there are many
problems by setting the Cienega and most
of them are caused by deforestation
trees cut to make way for palm oil
plantations and the ensuing aridity
jungle has also been replaced by pasture
land for cattle and then there's the
increased frequency of any new events
which dry out trees and reduce the
Cienega water levels nature is
completely out of kilter locals are
looking for solutions
oh my EDA has joined forces with other
Fisher men and women and founded an
association to protect the biotope with
more sustainable fishing practices they
now use smaller nets with a larger mesh
to avoid overfishing and to ensure
stocks can replenish
we've laid out some ground rules we
agreed that if anyone casts a net in the
conservation zone as they have done here
that we'll pull it out sometimes we burn
them a further aspect of local
conservation efforts is targeted
reforestation seeds are gathered and
cultivated in tree nurseries until
they're ready to be planted many
residents have played a role in the
deforestation lots of people here have
destroyed trees to gather firewood they
light bonfires on the water's edge and
grilled the fish they've caught or they
collected to take home to their kitchens
here in La Motta like in most other
parts of the region a lot of people live
from fishing in the afternoon volunteer
conservationists hold a meeting the 13
women and four men have come their aim
is to ensure the survival of the Cienega
a unique biotope and with it their
livelihoods at the air divi divi tree
nursery seeds and saplings of local
plants are cultivated and prepared for
planting they're all useful
this is an vita plant it has to be
cultivated from seedlings it's fruit can
be cooked and drunk as juice we're going
to reintroduce the plant and the Cienega
the conservationists make their own
fertilizer from cow dung sand and banana
shrubs as an incentive the aid
organization TNC pays residents for
their plants the Cienega used to be home
to around three thousand nine hundred
species of plant the fact that so many
have died out has wide-reaching
consequences the Boca Chica fish has
died out because there weren't enough
trees on the riverbanks that's why we
decided to replant trees it means the
fish stocks will regenerate to trees
along the water's edge provide aquatic
life with shade and also nutrition when
the fruit is ripe it falls into the
water and the fish can feed on it so
Laura is another village on the Cienega
here in a side street is a further
example of a local initiative to ensure
food security during the dry season a
household garden
the houses here usually have small yards
where owners have planted fruit trees
vegetables and herds some locals are
also planning to raise animals for their
meat and ducks and chickens for eggs the
houses used to have huge backyards
people weren't aware that they could
grow useful plants in the yard is a way
of economizing they are now learning to
cultivate different types of plants and
about how to use the resources neighbors
discuss what to grow with a view to
trading with each other that way they
maximize the range of produce this
household garden is exemplary the
project is helping locals raise enough
to keep themselves fed even during the
dry season and looming on the horizon is
the next El Nino which will mean less
rain the weather pattern is growing more
and more frequent say the fisher folk
making life even more challenging on the
Cienega
[Music]